de subdivision de logements,
c'est plus compliqué.
- Claude Charest et sa conjointe
n'ont pas le coeur à remplir
des boîtes. Un avis d'éviction
les force à quitter
leur nid douillet.
CLAUDE CHAREST, locataire évincé
- Ça fait mal, après 23 ans
dans un logement qu'on a mis
à notre goût, qu'on a décoré,
qu'on a même participé à rénover
avec l'ancien propriétaire.
C'est assez difficile
de quitter.
- L'entreprise Opti Plex,
qui a acheté l'immeuble
de huit logements du quartier
Limoilou, entreprend des
travaux majeurs pour rénover
et subdiviser le bâtiment.
Le couple a contesté
un premier avis pour rénovation
majeure, en 2019. Mais,
en décembre dernier, il a reçu
un avis d'éviction légal.
Les locataires sont
non seulement forcés
de quitter leur appartement,
mais aussi le quartier.
- On déménage de secteur
complètement. On est déracinés
pour s'en aller à Lévis.
- C'est un phénomène qui est
en forte augmentation à Québec.
- Et particulièrement
dans les quartiers centraux de
la capitale, selon le BAIL, un
organisme d'aide aux locataires.
JONATHAN CARMICHAEL, Bur. info.
logement, Québec métropolitain
- On a quelque chose comme sept
fois plus d'appels cette année
qu'on en avait il y a deux ans
pour ce sujet-là.
Les rénovictions, les évictions
pour agrandissement,
les reprises de logement...
- Des tactiques, selon lui,
pour augmenter de façon
importante le prix des loyers.
Les propriétaires ont refusé
notre demande d'entrevue,
mais affirment que ces travaux
sont essentiels. La Corporation
des propriétaires immobiliers,
elle, rappelle que les
propriétaires doivent assurer
la rentabilité d'un parc
immobilier vieillissant.
HANS BROUILLETTE, dir. Corpor.
propriétaires immobiliers du Qc
- Le seul moyen, c'est
de pouvoir rendre vacants
les logements par des moyens
légaux, ou illégaux dans
certains cas, on le voit, pour
ensuite relouer le logement
à des prix qui vont être
possibles... qui vont rendre
possible de rentabiliser
les travaux en question.
- La ministre des Affaires
municipale et de l'Habitation
se dit sensible au sujet.
Son attachée ajoute
par courriel que :
Claude Charest est résigné.
Un logement neuf l'attend
à Lévis, avec un loyer
trois fois plus cher
que celui qu'il payait ici.
Ici Camille Carpentier,
Radio-Canada, Q